like Lance enough no I think ah yours
Chester Hospital sure I don't wanna
mustn't open it when you close friend be
on your lap hi that's the closer she's
ever come to kind of flirting with me
[Laughter]
[Music]
my son Greg Alba is my name for cheery
guys's name highlight handy I'm more
hand time how to's the Morgan and Ashley
they're showing you how to do intros
right now go check out their channel
hey what's up on a time in Venice is the
trailer we're going to watch cool it
supposed to be funny I think this comedy
movie I gotta go to steal back to drugs
for these gay guys so I get my dog back
carefully funny
whoa
okay
[Music]
[Music]
big storm come I count on you to be is
balanced in my life they stole my dog
but delicacy in my country right come on
hey out on the field not after what
happened
no way - Gus good dad you go where's my
call we came to our dealer
oh no name socket Bogdan you any of your
deal
where's my daughter here's the daug that
[ __ ] briefcase no michael finer on
youtube over a block please much worse
look is it a girl
I want my dog back don't wash your hands
are actually thing for you two
the outbreak
what we've got a lot more serious
[Music]
what is this banana walnut still have
cinnamon oh gosh not like go to 5g I
[Music]
really want to see it do you really yeah
I mean looks fun it looks like a cross
between John wick and what's that cat
movie Keanu Keanu is like it's like us
and die hard and this makes sense John
Goodman constantly is showing up as
these supporting characters you know a
lot of information
he's always plays now as you do towards
the supporting roles who can just
provide a lot of facts on something a
lot of commentary on something just
rated R and it look like it's gonna be a
pretty violent I feel yeah you know this
movie has this weird look where it's
like there's a huge cast in here but it
feels like a low-budget film yeah but
you actually got a little bored this is
from the people who wrote the movie
cop-out which is considered when our
Bruce Willis is worst films it was a
film where it was really well known I
was around the time when everyone
started noticing that Bruce Willis just
doesn't care about the movies he doesn't
because he's doing lines because he
bored more agency and makes the money is
feeling like it's going to be
entertaining it's gonna be very
entertaining yeah the villain kind of
looked like a Hispanic kevin federline
little bull
well Jason Momoa he's working a lot I
mean he has Aquaman going on what is
that noise it's Aquaman movie called a
bad batch coming out and I think it's a
really charming actor and I like it's
nice to see him loosen up and do a
comedic roles everything is doing seems
rather serious just roll an Aquaman
looks a little bit more like you
[ __ ] look it's actually garbage
right now let me actually see it
that's fascinating nice already here so
it's nice to see him loosening up Bruce
Willis you might be having a fun time he
really seems like he just doesn't give
me a nice name she always looking at it
do you think that it's like they're
trying to kind of be like a funny
version of John with you oh it's always
been John with Jimmy freedom yes all
right killer like this is going to be
like a joke on I think it's kind of a
spoof of like crime action thrillers
yeah it seems like it's a spoon I would
think so I know that they go and they go
for that yeah it's just the last like 30
seconds of the cheddar rule like all of
it is like it's not losing its sense of
fun I mean it seems like a little bit
off in the direction at times as a
low-budget quality seems to kind of work
against it I wonder this is their first
time directing they did a short film
before this this is their first feature
film they're directing okay yeah good
for them it does look like a
first-timers movie I'll get Elsie it
looks like a first-time they are doing
this film but if they were able to get
like the trust of all these people it is
huge cast involved I'm a huge Silicon
Valley man I'll meet you yeah [ __ ] yeah
Thomas mill did I just caught up I bet I
just had watch what's having her don't
mess she makes it laughing strange is
going on a mortgage [ __ ] now she's
bragging okay we like it what's up sit
here and allow the laughing building oh
my god we lost her anyway on my phantom
Orion Thomas Middleditch I do like him
oh the guy from Silicon Valley yeah I
like him a lot funny yeah it's cool to
see him doing a movie role as well it's
like the main appealing part of this
show to me is just the cast yeah yeah
for sure they look like they're having
fun like my favorite moment in the
trailer is when Jason Momoa was doing
the 42 thing Bruce Willis's in his face
he points up and be like I just seen all
those guys in
acting John good makes it okay to be was
their only buddy you can just for like
Halen
yeah it looks like that looks like a
hangout movie she's gone no no no she's
in another like a 40-year okay so you're
gonna say this because I thought it the
funniest thing in the world would I
thought you might respond I see it
doesn't look like the greatest film to
me but it looks like Jimmy Bobby see it
looks like a Morgan film like rent it
you know yes Morgan yeah yeah like
ride-along but not I just feel like a
movie like you like you know you're a
pizza yet friends over you watch you
like it's like oh my gosh oh really pay
attention
I'm just slightly confused on the town
because I can't tell if it's exactly a
spoof or it's trying to be it's only
help me missus I'm hoping it's a suit
because you're like first thing you
think of is John wick yeah I really call
his comment solid just what I see right
here don't wait yeah I was old way
merciless remember what he used to be so
sexy I feel like he's always with the
same me even when he we see everything
the first diver no not go watch your
first dialogue don't recommend friends
brew let me let me he looks good for the
club you dad when I date him
yeah you date a bald guy I mean any
lawyers might shave his head he's blah
blah choice I think yeah I think he was
like moldings in the house worth
although I'll tell you I need to know
how a larger is because my older man is
Matt Damon
my older man is Robert Downey jr. yeah
1955 so from you the math 50 55 plus 7
he is 362 now yeah 50 plus 1955 a 2005
at five more years you get 2010 Sony be
55 at 7 to the
17 he's 62 yeah I just look sad to me I
thought I saw an interview of him in the
90s on Inside the Actors Studio and he
was talking about I wanted to stop doing
action movies and I want to just focus
on doing a real dramatic work because he
comes from the theatre the few films
we've seen him deal word it's like
serious work he does a great job in it I
feel like the most popular like serious
role he did was a sick sense where
there's no action in it yeah but he does
an amazing job in them yeah I just kind
of feel like that career path that he
tried doing didn't pan out for him what
he really wanted to do so now he's kind
of just stuck in like muck I'll just
cash a check for another dull action
bill seems like he's doing happy doing
this film because it's with his friends
yeah I mean I hope with the cast and
hanging out with everyone on set would
make us a lot more fun to be a part of
all right
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bill 3-ring that my fans
you Morgan Ashley ender that's what I
call my nipples how to use a Morgan and
Ashley desert youtube check it out come
join us on patreon
that's right mentioning that [ __ ] now
come join us there